[Musique]
j'adore david je t'aime tellement gary
oublierai jamais jour on s'est rencontré
et escargots comment tu t'appelles car
il y a un culot conçoit copains tu
rentres et garonnais d'harry la rooney
car il avait garé le ou non
kerry c'est plus qu'un coup de pub en
2020 laventure commencent les eaux me
laisse pas les amis faire des 100
questions je roule tout seul dans un
nouveau monde la cité perdue d'atlantic
city
on va pas perdre notre concentration
patrick c'est pas notre genre de perdre
avec un héros dc 1 patrick sur lequel on
peut miser met tout sur le jeune patrick
sepa nc-17 ça s'écrit avec un an tout
suffisant tom l'eponge le film éponge en
eaux troubles
ça va être une super aventure entre
copains pour la vente hier patrick qui
perd pas ses locaux ça tombe bien je
suis très douée pour repasser
[Musique]